welcome back to pj chain design today we
are going to talk about how to do the
design under the bezel in this area to
be accurate
are you ready let's get started
[Music]
so that's coming into the front view and
we want to draw a circle use a command
circle
type in 0 and i want to set up a
diameter for 16 millimeter and this will
be our ring size
and then i'm gonna coming into the top
to draw a cabochon stone so basically
i'm gonna snapping into the zero again
and depends on how big your cabochon is
going to be we're going to use the
command sphere and we're pretty much
just going to 1d scale on this sphere
for the capuchin stone the back is
always flat so let's go ahead to draw a
box and cut it somewhere about here and
we simply just want to use the boolean
difference command and difference this
sphere out of this box
so then we have this sphere here
as our capuchin stone
all right so let's go ahead and make a
seat first i'm gonna coming into here
and pretty much just draw a box starting
from the midpoint coming over here it's
a little bit
depth about this size and i simply just
going to draw another box starting
from here and going up you don't have to
have this one too tall as long as you
have a room to fall over to set the
stone that will be fine and let's go
ahead to
trim each
other by trimming
the one in the middle
and let's go ahead to join them
we may not need this one right here so
that's exploded everybody and we just
want to delete that one let's go ahead
join one by one so one two three four
five six and all of them uh join it
together into one curve now if you are
going just doing for the render
purpose that you may want to lower down
this
and moving in adjust a little bit even
though you are cutting into the stone
the render won't see but what we like to
do is giving a nice fillet so let's go
ahead to use the fitted command
for fitted curve that's starting fitted
for maybe point
six for the radius
snapping here and here on the other side
i want to have something a little bit
smaller 0.2
and go from here to here all right so
now we have this let's go ahead to
making a bezel
and we want this coming into the center
on the top view so let's go ahead to the
front view and we're going to use the
command for projector 2c plan and then
we'll delete the input right there and
then so we'll have this one
we'll have this curve right in the
center
so making into the bezel as a surface we
are coming to the surface and using the
command for revolve
and snapping into the end point
n axis you simply just holding the shift
key and click on anywhere on the top
coming back to the top view we want to
make sure it's 360 degree and then we'll
get the bezel like this
and now we want to design under bezel
area so that's coming over to creating
a surface first so we want to come in
here
using the curve command and we want to
coming down something like this
and going inside and this will be this
curve
this will be the curve for me to
creating the surface we're gonna use the
same command revolve and snapping into
the zero
on my top view holding the shift key and
snapping anywhere on that green axis and
coming into the top we want to make sure
it's 360 degree so this is will be there
just for the reference we need to see
what is the area to creating
the design
before we do that we probably want to
finish the ring shank so let's go ahead
to draw the arc using the arc command
snapping into the zero coming over here
as soon as you are over 1.5 millimeter
and coming back like this i always like
to have the ball in this taper so i'm
going to move the control point on the
bottom and then we'll have something
tapered like that
then i'm going to use the line going
straight holding the shift the first one
or two you might want to make sure that
it is going straight so that will look
really nice blend there and i wanted
this coming up like this
and then you can always adjust feel like
this is a little bit kinky there so i'm
going to have this one coming down just
a little bit
this one coming out a little bit
to get something like this
so once you have that then we can do our
sweep i only need to create half of a
ring shank so i'm going to do is split
this curve in half so that's using the
split command and make sure on the top
you have to click on the point we want
to split on the quadrant and the
quadrant so
we'll have this into two
we want to split this one on the bottom
as well so that's using the split
command again using the point
split on the quadrant as well so we
don't need this half there let's go
ahead to
creating the cross section so on the
bottom i would like to have the cross
section
we want to use the command for rectangle
corner and if you right click will be
the conic corners and we want to use the
three points so that's snapping into the
point one point two on the perspective
and move it back to the right view
and kind of moving your mouse in a
little bit so now you will have this
profile there let's go ahead to move
this profile
back to this endpoint
now we don't need to have this one go
all the way inside so that's using a
split command one more time
and we want to split with the point
and coming over here so now we have this
one that we can did it so
to be easy to see
let's join this first and i want to turn
them into
the red color so it's easier for you to
see now let's do a test if we are going
to do the sweep two rail you got rail
one
you got rail two you got this cross
section and we'll pretty much get the
ring shank like this i don't really like
this bumpy i actually wanted to go from
really wide and getting really narrow on
the top so what i'd like to do is using
the commands called duplicate ages you
can type it d-u-p-e then it will show in
the command bar and you can simply just
duplicate this edges make sure you join
them so then we will have that
curve over there let me marking into the
red color as well all right so for this
one i would like to get them thinner so
we're going to get them into something
like this
once you set up everything let's do
sweep two rail one more time the command
sweep two rail we're gonna do rail one
rail two
cross section one and cross section two
and make sure that they are aligned i
always like to align them into
the inside of the ring and make sure
they are facing the same direction okay
when you click ok
you're going to see something like this
still have a little bit bumpy there
so i want to click on the maintain high
so it won't change the thickness based
on the distance in between those two
curves so i will get something like this
if you like the result just go ahead and
click ok and then you will have
something like this since we only do the
half all we need to do is mirror to the
other side so using the command mirror
and we want to snapping into the end
point holding your shift key
and
join them so then you will have the ring
shank ready okay
now since i already cut it a circle for
my ring that i set it up for 16
millimeter i'm just gonna do it one more
time so i have a circle there
what i'm going to do is using that
circle to trim this reference
surface so then we have this area to do
our design okay
now everything set it up i'm going to
show you two way
the first way if you go ahead to create
uv curve
you're going to see this is what
happened
you see overall surface and then you
also see this line right there
if you use the command shrink
trim surface
first
and they feel like this is nothing
happen but
if you
create a uv curve command one more time
you're going to see something like this
all right so let me explain to you
what's the differences
the differences of this guy and this guy
is the first one
on my top view this one right here is
actually
the history
for before it gets trimmed before the
surface gets trimmed that's why you got
those distant there
this one since we use the command shrink
trim surface so the surface well going
very close to whatever that is
um to the age so i always like to use a
shrink trim surface first and to be more
accurate
all right so let's do our design i'm
going to delete this one
and i simply want to draw some triangle
but to be super accurate
i'm going to explode it this one
and i want to pick up this curve and use
the command divide and i simply just
going to divide it into 10 section there
all right so if i have a triangle going
in between
i can connect it those lines so i'm
going to make a copy using a copy
command selecting all the point that i
have and
copy to the other side so simply what i
like to do it's going up and down to
having my triangle design like this
okay so once i have it i'm going to use
that to creating a thickness there so
i'm going to use the commands called
offset
and i want to offset them into 0.4
millimeter
and make sure i want them to be on both
sides maybe 0.4 is a little bit too weak
maybe we wanted 2.6 to be more solid
and i we wanted to have it on both sides
for 0.6 millimeter so we no longer need
this one let me just did it this and
this is the area that we need
all right so this is the design that we
have let me explode this one we also
need the top and the bottom so i'm gonna
go ahead to use the command for offset
curve again
moving down about point eight millimeter
this one moving
not moving copy a line up for point
millimeter as well so we need those
triangle design there let's go ahead to
using this one
and this one and we want to trim the
area
whatever outside of this two curves so
let's go ahead to trim this
so we have the middle design left we
want to trim everything on the bottom as
well
whatever pass that line
there okay we also need to trim those
extra
line and to keep those triangle in there
so i'm gonna trim it off
those and those
you have to kind of thinking into the
reverse way
to handle this
right so once you are done just go ahead
to
unselect this one and everybody else
should be
joined together and unselect this one
the one on the h we want to deselect
them and we want to join the rest of
them
all right so those are the design we are
going to flow it back so let me go ahead
to
mark it into the red color all right so
to flow it back to the surface we need
to creating a surface as a reference
surface first so that's using the
command for rectangular plane and was
snapping from this point to this point
all right and then we're gonna coming
over here
finding where is the seam as you can see
there's a darker line there so that
means that's the h
let's go ahead to pick up all those red
color there
not the point on the top
and so we have those curves we want to
flow a long surface that's the command
we're going to use and we're going to
come in let me make sure it is in the
ghost view so we're going to make sure
we pick up one of the corner and coming
over here to pick up the target for the
other side of the corner and you can see
it is coming really well to this surface
so now they're coming into the surface
we can trim and sometimes when they uh
moving to the top not necessarily they
will be exactly accurate
to the surface but we can give it a try
we're going to use a trim command and if
i pick up this one am i able to trim
this one yes i can if you are not like
what i have here you have a hard time to
trim it you can just pull them back to
the surface and that should do the trick
so that's using the trim command i'm
going to trimming all this triangle
surface out
by doing so
all right so now we have this only on a
surface right so we need to creating the
thickness let's go ahead to use the
command for offset now offset has the
offset curve and offset surface make
sure you use the command for offset
surface and we want to offset inside so
let's say i want to offset inside for
one millimeter
and i want to solid equal yes and make
sure all the arrow is pointed inside
and then i will create those thickness
there now i'm looking at this and
realize my ring shank it doesn't meet
into the top and that doesn't look good
because feel like something is broken
there so what i like to do is actually
changing that profile and i want to redo
the ring shank i'm going to delete the
ring shank right here
and i'm going to pick up the profile
and use 1d scale so you're coming here
for the command 1d scale you want to
snapping into this point and point out
whatever inside of that shape all right
so that way will guarantee i think it's
pointing out way too much um
so let me do it one more time 1d scale
coming here and we actually want to
coming into the side view and because of
the angle that's why it is coming out
there so i'm going to
have it just a little bit longer and i
want to use the rotate tool to rotate it
going inside of it right so that way it
will
work better it will have enough length
it doesn't feel like it's broken over
there and i'm going to moving this point
to the quadrant there
all right so let's give it a try and see
if the ring shank worked better
let's use the command for sweep two rail
you got rail one rail two
and you got this cross section and also
this cross section as well make sure
that they all line up to inside of the
ring
and i'm gonna move it this one to here
and then facing the same direction make
sure maintain high is checked
and i also wanted to record history
because it look a little bit too thin
there let's click ok
now if this look too thin to you
you can
because we recorded history so we can
kind of play with the real time to make
it thicker all right so if that look
alright let's go ahead to have this one
to mirror to the other side
by using the mirror command and join
them together right it will say you
break the history that's okay we no
longer need to change it and we can use
the command cap cap
to make it into solid
let's take a look on the render view
all right that's how you
transfer design from a flat surface into
this curved surface there if you like
the way i model i have a lot more video
on the membership program
consider joining the membership that is
supporting as a small youtuber like me
to keep making the video
or click the thanks button on the right
bottom of the video
a small donation it can help me in the
long way thank you for watching and i'll
see you next
[Music]
you